こんにちは　はじめしゃちょーです
えーもう知っている方もいると思いますが
なんとこの度…
えーあの有名ブランド
コラボ商品を作らせていただきました
ありがとうございます［拍手］
Samantha Thavasaですよ
なんかすごい可愛くてこう華やかなイメージがあって
あのそうのような女の子らしいブランドとわたくしのような
こんな男めがゴラボ…あざす！
バックとかTシャツ作らせていただいたんですけども
やっぱオシャレに普通に使ってもらいたいってことで
結構デザインとかサマンサさんの人と
すごい色々考えて作らさせていただきました
で、今回ですねこれをきっかけに
Samantha Thavasaのイベントに登壇させていただいたり
ガールズアワードのランウェイを歩かせていただいたりしたので
是非、そちらのそちらの模様をご覧ください
どうぞ
♬〜（Give It Up -Ramin Feat. Kajsa Borg
はじめ）こんにちはー　司会者）こんにちは
はじめ）〜〜の方こんにちは
はじめ）今日はよろしくお願いします
司会者）よろしくお願いします
司会者）これのね他にもバックがございますが
はい、というわけでいかがだったでしょうか
あの余談なんですけど
ランウェイ歩く時めっちゃ姿勢良くないとダメだったんですけど
あの僕ウォーキングの先生に
姿勢がクソ悪いってめちゃくちゃ怒られました
ありがとうございます
はい、そして今回のコラボ商品なんですけども
まず1つ目がこちら
全4種類あるんですけども
なんか個人的には青だったら
男の子でも使えるんじゃないかなと思っております
うん、全然ありだと思う
僕が書いた所沢の顔がチャームポイントです
そしてキャンパスバックえー2種類あります
めぐみちゃんのやつと所沢のやつですね
そしてこちらキャンバストート
所沢とめぐみちゃんが服を着て
ハートに囲まれて可愛く2人寄り添っております
可愛い
そしてこちら所沢とめぐみちゃんのチャームも売っております
バックにちょっと付けとくだけでもめちゃくちゃ可愛いですね
で、あとはTシャツを5色準備しました
えーっとまずはこちら
えー、ジェ　ジェ　ジェ
ビ　マンジャー　ディ　ラ　なんとかー
あのー
まぁ日本語で言うと
えーと日本語書いてないバージョンと
日本語が書いてあるバージョンがあります
えー、白、紺色、黒、グレー、ピンクの5色準備しました
そしてですねお店の方に“サマンサクロワッフル”っていう
お菓子が売ってるんですけども
そのサマンサクロワッフルも
所沢とめぐみちゃんのコラボ商品として作ってもらったので
是非食べてみてください
で、こちらのコラボ商品なんですけども
買える場所が決まっておりまして
動画の概要欄に載せておきますので、是非そちらからのチェックしてみてください
是非、男の子も女の子も買ってみてください
【はじめしゃちょーエンディング】